the One Piece manga just showed the
secret ruler of the world government
speaking for the very first time and
with just a single word we learned that
the ancient war between the world
government and the ancient Kingdom might
actually have been an insane love
triangle drama that changed the entire
world and at the center of this all is
this brand new character who was Queen
of alabaster at the end of the white
century and in this chapter we get hints
about her crazy ties to EMU Joy boy and
even Amazon Lily and you're absolutely
not ready for the incredible theory
about characters from the void Century
that we'll be discussing at the end of
this video but for now we're starting
with the former queen of alabaster Lily
and just like with the Holy nights last
week we're introduced to this character
for the very first time in this chapter
when Cobra the current king of alabasta
at least before he was assassinated as
the five Elders about the past he
comments that the 20 swords jammed into
the ground before Emo's Throne belonged
to the original 20 kingdoms that found
the world governments and he then asks
about Lily apparently she was the queen
at the end of the world Century making
this only the fourth name character who
is absolutely confirmed to be from this
time period along with joyboy and
Tanisha and Toki oh and another one that
we'll be discussing later on however
after the war she disappeared and was
never seen again Cobra mentions that of
the 20 swords only 19 actually remain
and he even goes so far as to confront
the gurosei about the will of D about
which the royal family has passed on
information through the centuries which
does seem to be connected to Lily and
the founding of the world governments
now where did Lily go and why is she
important well let's see if we can
figure that one out first of all you
might remember that at the end of the
Void Century the 20 kingdoms defeated
the ancient Kingdom and then formed the
world governments we first learned in
chapter 722 that the other 19 rulers
went up to marijua and became the
celestial dragons however Lily and
alabaster refused to join them in the
holy land now why did she do this well
there are a few reasons that we're going
to speculate the most likely one is that
somehow the country of alabaster was
actually friends with the ancient
Kingdom and joyboy we do know this
because in chapter 202 it is confirmed
that Alabaster has been keeping a ponig
live pointing to pluton Hidden from the
world government ever since the what
century which kind of also connected to
wano and as you know not just any random
Kingdom can have access to these stones
and that is because the pony glyphs
record the true history of the Void
century and other information that the
ancient Kingdom did not want the world
government to erase from history and we
see all throughout the story that the
pony glyphs were given to the allies of
the ancient Kingdom all throughout the
world including Fishman Island zo
shandora wano and apparently Alabaster
and even though they've had this Pony
glyph for over 800 years Cobra still
fiercely protected the secrets even
willing to sacrifice his own life to
stop crocodile from finding it in other
words clearly it was important and
probably not just something that they
randomly had lying around so how does
this connect back to the original Queen
Lily well if Alabaster and Lily were
friends with this ancient Kingdom then
we have to ask how they ended up being
one of the 20 kingdoms that defeated the
ancient Kingdom and formed the world
governments and while we don't know for
sure it is possible that someone from
Alabaster maybe even Lily herself
betrayed the ancient Kingdom which
helped the 20 kingdoms win the war maybe
they killed joyboy or somehow gave the
20 Kingdom secret information but
whatever the reason is it seems like the
outcome caused Lily to reject the other
kingdoms and even her own kingdom
disappearing entirely from the world and
so with this in mind let's take a closer
look at who Lily actually could be what
she might have done and also the tangled
web of her relationships from the void
Century so do get your popcorn ready
because we're about to dive head first
into a juicy love affair here starting
with Lily and joyboy who could very
easily have been in love with each other
now let me explain for the longest time
in the story we knew that joyboy and
zunisha were from the void century and
now that we know that Lily wasn't well
it makes sense that she would be
connected to the other two as well now
this could just mean that the kingdom of
alabaster was friends with the ancient
Kingdom and Lily and joyboy became
friends this way as well just like Luffy
and Vivi or maybe Lily was a pirate
since the ancient kingdom was likely a
kingdom of pirates and she only became
queen of alabaster for a short time
after the war but however they met we do
know that she gave up everything for
some reason after the war and what is
the only thing that we know for sure
about the war well that the ancient
Kingdom lost and joyboy couldn't fulfill
his promises and plans wait we we do
know this right I mean Oda isn't going
to trick us with this either is he but
it does make a lot of sense to me that
she was either heartbroken that joyboy
had died during the war or that she was
so ashamed of betraying him that she
decided to abandon her life as Queen but
then where did she go well there is one
obvious place that would fit perfectly
with what we've explained so far that is
the island of women Amazon Lily now
clearly both the character and the
island share the name Lily and even in
Japanese this word is written in the
exact same way in Katakana which by the
way did you also know that in Japanese
culture the lily flower can represent
Purity revenge or even a final goodbye
for the debt all depending on its color
but in chapter 514 we learn about Amazon
Lily which is a country of women only
men are not allowed on this island
except for Luffy now of course and the
warrior women will literally kill any
man who tries to intrude on their sacred
Islands so let's see we have a
potentially heartbroken Queen who left
her kingdom possibly after her lover was
killed kind of makes sense to me that
she would form a new kingdom where she
would literally never have to see
another man like ever again also you do
have the connection Cobra and Boa
Hancock so that kind of connects alabast
and Amazon Lily and even if Lily wasn't
in love with joy boy it could have been
another man who broke her heart or
betrayed her and there is one character
in particular who will we be discussing
in just a moment but back to Amazon Lily
there is also the famous love sickness
like we see with Boa Hancock who is
literally dying because she has fallen
in love with Luffy and this sickness has
also affected other rulers of Amazon
Lily so the deadly illness might have
started with Lily herself 800 years ago
and by the way one Japanese theory that
I've seen about this is actually so
crazy that I just need to share it with
you here quickly because it actually
connects crocodile and ivankov and Lily
based on this chapter you see some
people in the Japanese one piece
Community have been wondering how Amazon
Lily sustained their population over
time I mean we do know that sometimes
women go out to get pregnant and then
come back home to have children but what
if the kingdom didn't start out like
that but they actually use the hormone
fruit to change people from men into
women just like we saw the Revolutionary
Army's ivankov do so and implement down
right after Amazon Lily and of course
this would certainly lead to more
credibility for our fun theory that
crocodile was originally a woman that we
have discussed on this channel here
before but honestly it is kind of out
there just want to mention it here but
anyways with all the speculation about
the distant past let's bring this
discussion back to the present chapter
because we do get to see Cobra interact
with the godosei as he asked them if
they know where Lily went now the
gorosei replied that they do not know
Liars oh sorry but if there is anyone in
marijua who does know about Lily it
would probably have to be the secret
ruler of the world emu and ever since
they were first introduced we have
believed that emu has been around since
the void Century I is that I guess
because they just look like an 800 plus
year old dude or women I mean we don't
even know if they're a man or woman at
this point but that is beside the point
because there are more hints that emu
knows about Lily and when I say hint
it's more because for the very first
time ever emu actually makes an
appearance and find finally Speaks now
of course it is only one word but it is
vitally important because he does say
Lily right before the chapter ends and
at this point my mind is going in a
thousand different directions not only
are we introduced to a super important
character from the void Century but we
also learned that they seem to be
important to EMU the secret ruler also
speaking of powerful Pirates sadly in
the real world most are less like Luffy
and Co and more like black Beatles if
they have a chance to steal your data
passwords and money online they probably
will luckily this is pretty easy to
prevent with the help of today's sponsor
Atlas VPN I'm sure you've seen enough
VPN ads in your life on YouTube so you
already pretty much know that you should
be using one aside from stopping ads and
malware and keeping your data and
browsing history safe you can of course
also unlock your favorite content from
all around the world for example why not
switch to Netflix Japan and watch all of
One Piece here also Atlas VPN is not
only reliable and fast with one
subscription covering all of of your
devices but it is also the most
affordable with great cost performance I
think especially right now because you
can grab Atlas vpn's big deal for just
1.83 cents per month plus three months
extra for free including a 30-day
money-back guarantee in case you don't
like it so protect your privacy and get
the many other benefits of Atlas VPN for
let's be honest a pretty ridiculously
low price and you can get this deal by
clicking the link in the video
description below also be quick as it's
a limited time offer and now back to the
video and so just like we explored the
possibilities with Lily and joy boy
let's discuss the potential hateful
heartbreaking and wholesome relationship
between Lily and emu and make sure to
subscribe to the channel because I do
promise not to break your heart when it
comes to one piece videos and just like
with joyboy it is possible that Lily and
emu were also in love at least one of
them with the other and there's even
some evidence to support this I mean
just the fact that the very first words
we ever hear from emu is Lily's name is
pretty significant also strong Severus
Snape Vibes anyone anyways and plus on
top of that in chapter 907 when we see
emu for the very first time they have
cut up a bunch of pictures and Bounty
posters of Luffy blackbit and shirahoshi
however the one picture that they don't
destroy is vivi's they just look at it
and so this could possibly mean that if
Vivi is a descendant of Lily I mean they
do share the last name after all then
maybe emo really cares about or wants to
meet the longtime descendant of their
former love and to make this idea even a
little bit crazier if emo and Lily we're
in love what if they actually had a
child and that child became the ruler of
alabaster so I do know it does sound
crazy but there is a possibility that
Vivi could be a descendant of emu and
that is why emo was holding her picture
just throwing that out there plus Lily
and Vivi do look shockingly similar so
that is one part of this puzzle
confirmed however if there was a both
sided or just one-sided relationship
between Lily and emu then we have to ask
why would Lily leave after the war
certainly emo is still alive so if their
relationship is actually true couldn't
they just have snuggled up in the big
castle well something would need to have
changed during the end of the war maybe
and this is where the love triangle
comes in Lily was in love with joy boy
and emu orb just with joy boy but emu
was in love with her and when emu and
the 20 kingdoms defeated the ancient
Kingdom Lily was so torn up about
joyboy's defeat that she left anyway or
even if she was just in love with emu
maybe she was so disgusted by something
emo did during the war that she didn't
want anything to do with them ever again
however I do admit that is way too much
speculation about a Lover's Feud so
let's Reign things in a little bit and
get to another possibility about Lily
and this time the former queen of
alabaster is putting on that big pointy
head herself that's right let's discuss
what could happen if Lily actually
became emu and let's start by digging
back into Japanese culture here because
the water lily are are also an important
symbol in Buddhism where they can
represent both resurrection and
Enlightenment so we have Lily who was
the former queen of alabasta and emu who
is possibly Immortal and is enlightened
as the secret ruler of the World by the
way emu in Reverse makes Umi which does
mean water or ocean in Japanese so if
you haven't connected the dots yet what
if Lily was reborn as emu when they
became the secret ruler of the world now
you can call me crazy but it does fit
with what we know about emu and with
everything else we've discussed so far
in this video because if Lily and emo
are the same person she could still have
been in love with joy boy especially
because she kept what we assume is Joy
boy straw hat in this big freezing Vault
plus emu is kept secret from basically
the entire world and no one seems to
know what happened to Lily after she
left Alabaster after the war oh wow this
is actually starting to make a lot of
sense to me right now but we will have
one even more insane theory for Lily at
the end of this video but in the
meantime we still have to look at the
unfortunate king cobra first because
while Cobra is questioning the godosei
this is when emu finally shows up and
while we don't know what exactly
happened in the scene somehow Cobra ends
up dead afterwards so he might have been
killed by the gorosei or maybe the shock
from seeing emu just led to COBRA Dying
by himself it does not look like that in
the photo he is in with Sabo either way
it does leave to an even more
potentially world-changing situation
because we do know that Sabo crashed the
secret party at some point later on so
we do have to ask did Sabo actually see
emu because if he did then the world
will never be the same because unlike
Cobra Sabo did get away so surely Saba
will tell Dragon about emu and then
there is no telling what will happen
will Dragon increase the pressure on the
world governments well he tried to leak
the information that there is a secret
world ruler to the rest of the world I
mean if he's smart he probably should
though I will say truthfully it is also
quite possible that Sabo didn't see emu
especially because it has been about a
month since this happened at the reverie
and while it looked like Saba was almost
killed at this island right here that
attack was not specifically meant for
Sabo since the gorosei basically said
that they had already planned to take it
out way earlier and honestly while it
would be cool if the world knew about
emu I think it would still also be
incredibly hype if the straw hats were
the ones to uncover emu's true identity
for themselves but most importantly with
all this talk about Lily and emu this
absolutely has to mean that VV is going
to be a super important character for
the end game of the story because we do
know she's a descendant of Lily so it
makes a lot of sense that she would
eventually learn about her ancient
ancestor plus it does look like she's
going to be reunited with the straw hats
very soon since she is on a ship heading
towards eckhit Island right now and
speaking of the end game let's discuss a
few final possibilities for what
happened to Lily including the theory
that could completely change the final
war of the story now first Lily could
have simply been killed by the world
government that is definitely one
possibility here second she could have
been the one to travel to wano and have
the pony glyphs made there but speaking
of wano there is actually one other
named character that we know about from
the void Century because in chapter 964
we meet this woman amatsuki Toki and she
would later go on to become the wife of
this chatley Samurai and she's actually
born over 800 years ago in the story now
as you probably remember that was only
possible because she ate the time devil
fruit which allows its user to send
herself or others forward into the
future and as we mentioned with Lily Joy
boy and zanesha there is an incredibly
High chance that all these characters
would have known each other since
they're being introduced that late in
the story so it does make sense that
Toki would have been a part of that
group as well especially because she was
specifically looking for wano who was an
ally of Joy boy and the ancient Kingdom
but the important thing to consider here
are toki's Powers that's right at this
point I am wondering if Toki actually
sent Lily forward in time as well and
that she is going to be arriving very
soon in the story and now hold on before
you get all angry about time travel
ruining the story again there are some
actual possibilities here that do make
some sense you see remember that when
Roger reached love tail and learned the
true history he knew that he was too
early to really use whatever he found on
the island to change the world and while
we have assumed that he was waiting for
Joy boy to reappear which has now
happened with Luffy there could actually
be more to this prophecy because what if
along with Luffy's Awakening someone
else from the void century was sent
forward to help the New Joy boy not make
the very same mistakes that the ancient
Kingdom wanted specifically I'm saying
that what if Lily was sent forward to
help Luffy in the fight against the
world governments might explain why she
is not there anymore and while we don't
know if she has any devil fruit Powers
we have have learned in echid island
that the ancient Kingdom had highly
advanced technology so what if Lily is
coming to help the straw hats use some
hidden technology or to counteract some
hidden weapon that the world government
has up its sleeve and maybe even another
possibility is that Lily is the ancient
weapon Uranus and that she was sent
forward to help win the final war and of
course this is all speculation in my end
and if Lily was sent forward that could
mean that other characters from the void
Century could show up as well but I do
think it's a real possibility and one
that could make for an even more hyped
Final War in my opinion at least and
actually since we're talking about
characters showing up from the white
Century here's one more bonus Theory
inspired by the Reddit user fleeton now
this theory is basically about what if
people from the void century were turned
into stone by the middle meronomi and
they are waiting to be revived for the
final war and while the previous user of
the middle meronomi definitely died and
wouldn't be able to revive the statues
themselves it's possible that there is
some other way to survive those statues
similar what they do in the anime Dr
Stone basically so maybe there is some
sake like big socket that has been Aging
for uh 800 years and when it is finally
ready it can be used to revive the
people from the void Century but
whatever happened to Lily and whether we
will see her again she is definitely a
part of the important information we
absolutely have to learn about the void
Century before the final war because one
thing we do know for sure is that the
world government won this battle 800
years ago and it's going to be a massive
challenge for the straw hats to take
them down this time and if you want to
learn everything that we can deduce
about this insane new group of
characters called The Holy Knights of
gods who could possibly be the straw
hats final opponents then you can watch
that video right there Shanks for
watching